Alright guys, so in this video we are going to learn about auto blocks. Now I'm pretty sure that you guys have heard a lot about auto blocks. And if you've been watching a lot of youtubers for X creators, I'm pretty sure that by now you know about auto blocks. But just for the sake of this course I'm gonna still teach it. Alright?
That's that makes sense. So what is an auto block? Now if we are new you should be
listening very very carefully. So when we get an impulsive move, I will repeat when
we get an impulsive move to the downside or to the upside price is going to
leave out some imbalance or fair value gap. Now above now the first candle of that fair
value gap that creates the, remember we talked about three candle pattern right. So we
got one candle, two candle and a third candle. Okay. So as I've said before, I'm going
I want to explain to you auto blocks in my own way.
All right?
I believe it works way better than what other people are teaching.
Because if you, I'm going to just say it quickly,
if you have been watching a lot of videos,
they always tell you that you should always pick
the very last candle of that impulsive move.
But that is absolutely wrong.
All right?
So first of all, you want to identify imbalance.
So we talked about the three candle pattern.
So this is one candle.
This is the second candle.
And this is the third candle, all right?
And we got fair value gap around this.
So this is fair value gap.
Now the very first candle, which is this, all right?
That is your autoblock.
So you just mark it out.
And this is from way you should be entering.
If you want to enter off the autoblocks,
I sometimes I enter off the autoblock.
If the imbalance is too big, OK?
Sometimes I just be directly entering from the imbalance.
So this is basically autoglog guys.
What you want to determine, first of all,
is a impulsive move.
It could be, as you can see, this is an impulsive move.
And by impulsive move, I mean a price action
that leaves imbalance.
And what we should be always keeping in mind
is that we should be only considering the autoblog
and imbalance in the premium zone
if we are looking to sell, okay?
So we are looking to sell, right?
So then we're gonna draw out our fib
and you can see price is above the 50% level.
So yeah, you can buy, sorry,
you can short it right around when price reaches the imbalance
for the optimized entry, you can just put your short position at this auto block and
yeah boom that is it. So I'm not going to explain complicated stuff. I'm just going to teach
you in the most easiest way so you can understand easily okay. Don't over complicate things
guys. It's just, I don't know, there's so many grooves that overcomplicate auto blocks so much.
All right. So keep that in mind and impulsive move that creates some sort of imbalance in the premium
or discounted zone. All right. And then the first candle, I don't care if it's a bearish candle
or a bullish candle, I just wanted to be the first candle of that imbalance. Okay, so remember
three candle pattern, one, two, three, the low of the first candle, the high of the second
third candle. All right, so I'm going to explain it again, just in case you didn't understand.
So this is imbalance.
But if the imbalance is too big, I enter of the autoblock,
which is this candle, the beginning of the autoblock.
Put your stop-loss right above it.
And boom.
Now, this is, of course, hindsight.
So yeah, this is autoblock.
Now, let me give you an example for if I can find it, of course.
OK.
I think I do find it.
I think this is in a
That I'm all right. Yeah, so we got the
Example here, but this is not the perfect example, but I'm just still gonna teach it all right, so we see we got a pull
push up
Push down and then we got another leg up
So we are gonna go first of all draw if if not you do so you can see this in a pulse and move that leaves the imbalance behind
All right, so let me go this out right around here is okay, so perfect voila
Now, after the impulse and move to the upside, we are going to wait for the price to fall
down into the discounted zone, which is below 50% of the Fibonacci deal.
Perfect.
Great.
Now, where is the imbalance?
You can see that we see imbalance around this level.
So we got imbalance.
The problem with it is that it is above 50% but if you look just below it, you can see
that this is auto-block.
The first candle that creates the imbalance.
So price falls into this autoblock.
But then we got another fair value gap around this level.
So we should be considering this as our autoblock.
And if we draw this out, you can see how perfect our entry is.
So you would have gone long here.
Of course, your stop loss was a bit huge, but look,
we are on a one minute timeframe.
So this is very small, okay?
And boom, and I'm explaining it on a one minute timeframe,
just to show you guys that price is fractal, okay?
So I hope you understood what I talked about here, okay?
First of all, we saw an imbalance around here,
but the imbalance was above the 50% area, okay?
But then price fell into this discounted auto block.
Now you kind of entered here as well.
Okay, as I said before, I sometimes enter off the imbalances.
If the imbalances short, I would enter here.
And as you can see in this scenario, the imbalances were small.
So I would have entered at this level.
But if you are only entering off the auto blocks,
Then you want to see you want to mark out the
the auto block in the discounted zone. So this was the first if you did enter here congrats, okay?
But as you can see the imbalance was about 50% this this could have been a risky trade, okay?
But then this auto block was way below the 50% level
Way to discount it. Okay, so this is like the perfect place for you to buy
and price falls into this level of course you're gonna enter a little above your
actual entry to deal with the spreads of your broker and as you can see price went
all the way up very very simple guys okay and not complicated at all let me see if
I can give you another example and then I'm gonna end the video so now of course
is hindsight guys and yeah you know and okay so let me see okay so we got the
market structure break now I consider wakes sometimes as a break as well
because you know it's just showing I shine a sign of strength that price can go
up. So I considered it as a Microsoft
break as well. And now you're gonna see
that we got this autoblog right around
here. Now of course, I'm just telling you
guys if you're just entering only
because of the autoblocks you're gonna
lose a lot because yeah of course my
job is to teach you autoblocks but I
don't usually recommend using autoblocks
like this but for the sake of this video I'm just gonna teach you anyways okay so
as you can see price broke through this level so we're gonna first of all draw
our Fibonacci too all right wait for the price to fall down into the premium
sorry discounted zone price comes down to the discounted zone and we got this
imbalance here so now I would personally directly enter off this imbalance
which is around here so you can see we have gotten this move right up right up
there. But then as you can see, we got this autoblog, all right? And price fell into it,
probably stopped you out. Of course it did because in my opinion, if you're using autoblogs like
that, you're always going to lose. I'm pretty sure that you have watched a lot of SMC videos.
Or you bought someone else's course and they taught you that you should be buying a
I thought a block putting your stop was right below it,
but eventually you get stopped out a lot
in my strategy videos.
I'm gonna clear everything to you.
So don't worry about it, but I'm pretty sure
you should be clear about auto blocks.
This was a long video and unnecessarily long video,
but I did, oh, I do hope that you got
some information out of it.
So don't just rely on auto blocks, guys.
mean yeah they are helpful but in a different way and I'm gonna teach you that
different way so see you guys in the next video